our community has enjoyed the gilchrist
orchard for decades and even with
everything going on right now 2020 is no
exception
rocky theist joins us live at the
pumpkin patch to show us how they're
keeping the fall
spirit alive hi rocky
hey kirsten okay we've moved away from
the pumpkin patch to the other thing
that gilchrist is so famous for
the legendary apple cider doughnuts and
yeah of course i tasted that dough and
it was delicious so
mark i have you here to tell us
introduce us to the legendary donuts
please what am i doing right now
well you're making our mini apple cider
donuts
and uh we make it with our own apple
cider
oh it's so good it tastes really good oh
god i'm making a mess
i'm making a mess sorry trying to get
fired already
all right let's let's turn this on let's
turn this bad boy on because i want to
taste these i've been hearing a lot
about them
so just besides the donuts we'll wait
for those to make but
you guys have another a huge menu
actually i think you can get here
so uh about mid october we'll have our
our uh pomegranates will be ready
delicious and then we also have some
pink lady apples hopefully they'll be
ready by
that time too i hear people are really
passionate about the pink lady awesome
they are
so uh right now we have the granny smith
apples as soon as they're done
basically the other ones should be
coming on okay and then of course your
snack bar your kitchen
so we make over here lance let's look at
this so we make our kettle
corn here these this is from scratch
caramel apples
delicious and our apple cider that we
make from our gala apples that we
harvest in july
and i have to admit i have i had a cup
of this and it is
delicious two of my favorite things
donuts and apples and you've
found a way to mix them together so i am
in heaven they came to the right place
right so you actually sell this
throughout the week people can come here
and pick up food
right so on tuesdays thursdays saturdays
and
sundays we've added sundays for the fall
season
and it's from seven to two
so uh if you come you can enjoy all this
stuff
i love it okay let's get back to the
donuts and while we're waiting for these
to get made quickly tell our viewers
a little bit about the history behind
the gill crease family orchard so the
gill creases
came to this part of town in the mid
20 mid 1920s
and then they homesteaded a lot grew
alfalfa
and other things they turned this into
the orchard in the mid 70s
1970s i love it and then
they have had it ever since so
ted gilchrist turned the gill crease
orchard into a
non-profit foundation before he died so
it has live on past his life well
thank you ted and thank you to mark i'm
about to try this legendary donut
is it going to burn my mouth though
maybe
wow okay yeah so to go boxes
available because all the food here is
to go and you can come join us
throughout the week on what days
tuesdays thursdays saturdays and sundays
okay from 7am to 2pm coming up later in
the show i'm gonna actually go
pick some pumpkins because i've never
done that if you can believe it or not
i'll sing back to you guys